what unusual methods did batman use to
heal a broken back how did he avoid
certain doom by a time travel how did a
battery bring him back to life keep
watching for all the wild answers
in the battle between good and evil
batman will seemingly do anything to
defeat his enemies even if that means
taking the dc universe's version of
steroids on steroids after all in the
fight between good and evil taking
performance enhancers apparently isn't
bad if the audience doesn't know about
it or if they're being used for a good
cause to that end batman once used the
super drug venom to gain superhuman
strength a highly addictive substance
was first introduced in batman legends
of the dark knight number 16. batman
doesn't use it in vain he does it to
save people and never fail on his
crusade due to a lack of strength again
even so he becomes addicted to venom
batman eventually hides out in the bat
cave to get clean and stay off the drug
although he succeeds in this endeavor
and bravely handles the withdrawal it's
not the last time venom causes problems
for him venom is eventually used to
create one of batman's strongest enemies
bane
in the nightfall story arc the
aforementioned bane broke the dark
knight's back after breaking down his
will for months the injury left batman
disabled with the replacement jean-paul
valley taking over as batman but luckily
gotham's greatest hero doesn't stay down
for long bruce wayne and loyal butler
alfred pennyworth tracked down a
holistic therapist chandra kiln solving
in an attempt to heal bruce from his
devastating injuries because the dc
universe is packed to the gills with
supernatural shenanigans chandra's
telekinetic abilities play a role in
fusing bruce's spine though kinsolvin
suffered some serious consequences and
was temporarily left in childlike states
bruce was once again good to go
batman has died on multiple occasions in
the comics luckily there are plenty of
enchanted things in the dcu that can and
have been used to fix him up the lazarus
pit is one such mystical construct it's
a pool that extends life and brings dead
people back to life batman has
inadvertently taken a dive into its
magical waters i know it is difficult to
believe but the pit is what keeps him
alive what has kept him alive for 600
years
in the comic story batman birth of the
demon batman and super villain raza
ghoul face off batman against all odds
is impaled both roz and the bat then
fall into a lazarus pit batman
eventually rises from the pit healed
that man didn't necessarily plan on
falling into the pit nor did he plan on
having to use it even so this mystical
pit allowed him to once again cheat
injury and death comic creators have
used some brilliant methods to bring the
dark knight back to full strength and
sometimes even back to life one such
technique is time travel which exists in
the dc universe and is a perfect example
of batman cheating death in the final
crisis storyline alien villain darkseid
takes batman out with his omega beams
though batman also manages a fatal shot
with a radeon bullet though batman is
presumed dead and his body is charred
the beams actually sent him back in time
and he's seen alive at the end of the
comic
he then goes on a journey through
different time periods to return to his
own surprising dick grayson who has
taken over his batman
and bob haney and jim aperos the brave
and the bold number 115 batman is
electrocuted leaving him brain dead if
this was any other person they probably
wouldn't be able to come back from this
devastating blow but we're talking about
batman here the atom a superhero who can
shrink in size yet still retain his
strength decides to shrink himself jump
inside batman's body and fight crime on
his behalf the atom controlling batman
results in yet another magical recovery
as this maneuver creates enough stimuli
to jumpstart batman's brain and
restoring though this entire storyline
might appear bizarre batman doesn't live
in a typical world it's comics
in detective comics number 644 through
number 646 by chuck dixon tom lyle and
scott hannah the electrocutioner does
what his name indicates to batman
resulting in his heart stopping luckily
robin came prepared by wearing an
insulated costume robin forces
electrocutioner to reverse the damage
the electrocutioner then uses his
electric gloves as a defibrillator to
shock batman back to life and just like
that batman was back another time in the
court of owls the talons get the best of
the superhero though they don't directly
kill him batman nearly drowns and his
heart stops luckily harper rowe
discovers batman and restarts his heart
with jumper cables that are attached to
a car battery there's nothing quite like
using everyday items to resurrect the
one and only batman to say this is
cheating death is an understatement as
batman actually did temporarily meet his
demise thankfully car batteries and
jumper cables serve more than one
purpose
in the dark knight rises bane once again
gets the better of batman and in an echo
of nightfall breaks the heroes back
putting the christopher nolan version of
batman played by christian bale at his
clear lowest point i will show you where
i have made my home whilst preparing to
bring justice
then i will break you to further stack
the deck against batman bane puts bruce
wayne in a cell in the underground
prison where bane grew up the pit yet
batman always proves to have plenty of
allies
fast forward to a fellow inmate punching
bruce in the back which apparently puts
a misplaced vertebrae or two back into
place bruce uses a rope harness to
essentially do therapy and train until
he's capable of walking again he
eventually climbs out of the pit and
lowers the rope so the other inmates can
escape too against all odds he regains
his strength and returns to battle
ultimately besting bane and upending his
plan the dark knight rises indeed
so you came back to die with your city
i came back to stop you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you